ces trois points les remboursements de
michael il est difficile de la sécu et
social la grogne des médecins
la réponse du musée la santé oms cyber
sécurité sociale se bat d'abord limiter
les dépenses à 100 pour sa prise en
charge à 100 % évolue beaucoup plus vite
que les autres et bien là ceci étant dit
il faut être clair quel sens cette
mesure où vous tapez de nombreux assurés
sociaux un gros effort ceux de l'ordre
de 5% pour des dépenses qui sont des
dépenses de but thierry lang
ce sont des centaines au titre mais
c'est un poteau en tête qui leur dit
attention vous allez voir le nez ça vous
avez quelques prescriptions pour une
affection ce n'est pas encore une fois
une infection grave est qu'il n'est pas
une hospitalisation à vous demande juste
la petite contribution qui matent que
vous êtes conscient que chaque août à la
sécurité sociale et à votre mutuelle de
la vôtre à ses dimensions je crois que
tout cela est raisonnable et je pense
que ça permet de responsabiliser genre
et cela à pernes peut permettre
d'ailleurs à chaque mutuelle de pouvoir
avoir des cotisations
justement parce qu'il ya un effort
d'économie qui réunit les trop tôt pour
dire c'est le printemps mais je crois
qu'on sort quand même de l'hiver en ce
sens que on sort d'une période très
difficile réalité sociale mais il faut
passer il faudra continuer mes gonds
pour tous est sérieuse et qu'elle
retrouve tout le monde que nous devons
retrouver un certain équilibre à
l'escalier social que il y va de
l'intérêt de tous et je suis chaud et le
médecin français qui viendront pour ma
part je confirme mon attachement profond
une jeune libéral vient d'ailleurs de
cannes et 80 c'est la revalorisation la
présence du général estime médecin de
famille parmi nous mon tout ça sans se
départir d'une certaine rigueur car la
rigueur d'aujourd'hui est la garantie